[Music]
a girl alone in the woods dead bodies at
her feet as screams echo from behind a
pounding door what's on the other side
carrie what's behind the door
nightmares your worst
nightmares
you don't want to know but i do and that
ladies and gentlemen is our theory today
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
wait a minute what what is behind that
door what is it what is it oh oh no it's
horrible oh gary was right it is my
worst nightmare kill it kill it with
fire kill it
whoo that is much better but some
threats aren't so easy to deal with for
an example look no further than
peacock's newest original series the
girl in the woods a series produced by
the masters of fright our good friends
at criptv for those of you who don't
remember the last time we talked about
crypt two years ago they are in my
honest opinion the best in the business
when it comes to modern day monster
movies they're known for creating short
horror films filled with original
creatures and uploading them onto places
like youtube and facebook the end result
lots of gore lots of scares and lots of
nights spent sleepless with the lights
on and pretty much all of it is done
with practical effects not cgi which
gotta say is just so refreshing in this
brand safe world of content that is 2021
crypt just isn't afraid to get up in
your face and legitimately terrify you
and then you know bite your face off i
don't know what sort of budgets they
operate on but the team over there have
been making incredible stuff for i'm
sure a fraction of what they're actually
worth for the better part of a decade
now which i gotta say is why i'm so
excited to see one of their stories the
girl in the woods get the attention of
nbc's new streaming service peacock to
receive the green light and budget to
get made into a full series of nine
episodes go team digital so now that
they're equipped with more time and more
money what i want to know is what to
expect what horrors do they have in
store for us and how is this new project
gonna connect to the mcu not that mcu
the monster cinematic universe you see
not only have they created dozens of
original terrifying new horrors since
2015 including the look-see the birch
soot mordeo and the sunny family cult
but they've taken it one step further by
connecting all of them thanks to small
little easter eggs and references we
know that pretty much all of their
twisted tales intertwine in some way and
the girl in the woods is no exception
see that symbol right there in that
mysterious door that very clearly acts
as the only thing protecting humanity
from whatever bloodthirsty sharp-toothed
creature is pounding away on the other
side yeah that is the iconic happy face
of the sunny family cult which in turn
dominoes its way into well i'm getting
ahead of myself so today we're getting
ready for halloween by doing a deep dive
into the scariest connected universe
that's out there crypts monster verse to
see what deadly surprises await on the
other side of that door in the upcoming
new episodes of the girl in the woods
let's start with what we absolutely know
this new streaming series on peacock
seems to be an updated take or retelling
of the original crypt 2 parter the door
in the woods and the girl in the woods
so those seem like a solid place to
begin in these videos we follow the
story of a young girl named carrie who
along with her friends makes the
itty-bitty itsy-weensy mistake of
accidentally opening an ancient portal
to a demonic dimension unleashing a
bloodthirsty monster that wipes out her
entire village you know classic
coming-of-age stuff hashtag relatable
the monster in question is the brute a
hulking unstoppable beast that rips
through anyone it meets and if you think
they're safe just because they're kids
well you haven't seen kryptv have you
[Music]
as the body count piles up we learned
that carrie's village isn't just any
secluded cult living in the woods it's
actually a group of protectors called
the colony united in the sole purpose of
defending the world from whatever
horrors exist behind the door and i mean
not to speak too ill of the dead but
you kind of blew that one guys you had
one job and now you're all dead but we
in the colony have a job to do what are
you doing dad
who you're the only ones that can
protect the world from the doom it's
never explicitly mentioned but it
appears that carrie's father is one of
if not the leader of the colony based on
his red outfit he is um not a great guy
practically using his daughter as bait
to get the brute back behind the door
but don't worry about it the brood is
more than happy to tackle him into
whatever heck dimension exists on the
other side carrie manages to close the
door but loses her arm in the process
she passes out in front of the door due
to blood loss and on that uplifting
image of a child slowly dying the first
video ends the sequel largely expands on
the first checking in with carrie seven
years later we get more clarity on both
the door and the colony it's like a
wound an open one to tear um
creatures can pass through it
it was the job of the colony to maintain
that bandage we see that carrie's
missing arm has been replaced with a
metal one complete with matching
assassin's blade we also learned that
not only is she a talented artist but
she's also a jaded monster hunter
burdened with regret over her innocent
childhood mistake i mean it was a
mistake that cost nearly a dozen of her
closest friends and family their lives
but still conquering the brute appears
to be her white whale as she repeats the
mantra over and over again fruit brew
come out of your old spare living one
more soul by the end of the video she
opens the door again to confront him and
uh yeah seven years of training amount
to nothing she immediately gets dunked
on losing yet again to the brute and
this time he's left to roam free so
not a great plan there carrie the story
ends with her committing to hunting it
and other monsters down like a
modern-day van helsing i mean you
literally have a glowing magic blade
built into your arms so not going that
route would just kind of be a waste now
like i mentioned some part of the new
peacock series seems to be a retelling
of these events notice the new actress
playing carrie and the new look of the
door but while it has a new look a lot
of the key details appear to be the same
carrie is still equipped with a false
hand and hidden blade in brief lashes we
see what appears to be the brute it
looks like she's continued her pencil
art hobby and again we hear about the
importance of the colony my colony and
all of our practices exist entirely to
protect the world from the awful things
beyond that door as such i would expect
this new series to hit on many of the
same beats as the original source
material carrie is the daughter of the
colony's leader who accidentally
unleashes monsters from behind the door
losing her arm in the process regretting
her mistakes she becomes a demon slayer
to make things right that i assume will
form our base story i know i've joked
about this before but it really is the
coming-of-age story story about growing
up and coming to terms with your
identity and past actions but based on
the fact that the trailers now show
carrie headed to a city called west pine
it looks like some normal civilians are
gonna be wrapped up in all this too
putting additional stakes on carrie's
monster hunting but it's the potential
for wider monster-verse stuff that gets
me really excited what other monsters
can crypt pull in and what other world
building elements are they gonna be
teasing we see here in the trailer that
carry is flipping through some sort of
tome a giant book of monsters that at
least in the online series serves as one
of the major connective threads
throughout the entirety of crips
universe same with the door while the
design seems to have visibly changed in
the new peacock series notice how
there's fewer etchings i wouldn't be
surprised if this was only for the
trailer to cover up some easter eggs
that might be coming later kind of like
how marvel is always altering their
trailers to hide key plot details in
fact the titular girl in the woods
carrie was set up to be the de facto
monster hunter of the entire franchise
throughout the girl in the woods video
were given teases about a mysterious
briefcase that carrie isn't allowed to
touch one
that you never let anyone open that door
and two that you never touch this
briefcase but when her mentor dies she
opens it up only to find a mysterious
diagram with the word monsino
watermarked across it the next item she
pulls out is a map of the u.s labeled
once again monsino so let's start off
with that first diagram it's a bit
difficult to read but by pausing and
enhancing like an fbi agent we can see
that this is meant to be a schematic for
the plane of torment realm of the
monsters we can assume then that the
colony's mysterious door is a portal
between the real world and this monster
slash nightmare realm and that's not all
the mention of the word torment here is
important because it connects back to
glowing purple rock fragments called
torment fragments scattered throughout
the crypt universe you see throughout
crypt's series we see repeated use of
glowing purple energy in the
spider-themed miss anity we see a
glowing purple spider descend from the
ceiling and another one crawl across the
screen while we look at her victims in
water's edge we see a deposit of purple
rocks near a haunted pond and most
explicitly in camp monster we see a
young boy being tortured by one of these
purple rocks which then transforms him
into a bore-like monster in fact the
original video of girl in the woods
flashes us to this very scene from camp
monster these rocks are from the portal
some of the creatures are created
directly from the portal others are
created right here on earth with the
help of these rocks these purple rocks
are the torment shards which as the name
implies connects them back to the door
and to the plane of torment even
carrie's blade is made using that
glowing purple energy which is
apparently powerful enough to scare away
the brute so it would seem that the
energy of the portal is both powerful
enough to create new creatures and also
destroy them when put in the right hands
so already you can start to see how the
girl in the woods peacock series has the
potential to be a hub of the rest of the
mcu with the mysterious evil door and
its torment energy acting like a source
for so many other of the franchise's
monsters but it also extends way beyond
this to understand why though let's look
at the other secret from that briefcase
the monsino map the name most directly
connects it back to the tv one-off
taste which is all about a suburb that's
transformed into cannibals via corrupted
meat got your free sample here from
monsino farm no wonder they say there's
no such thing as a free lunch
it's a little bit too camp for my taste
but as carrie's map shows monsino has
their hand in other industries as well
including pharmaceuticals and biotech
pay close enough attention and you'll
see that monsino's therapeutics division
is creating monsters under the brand
name somnadine see the monsino logo on
the pill bottle from dream screechers
and wouldn't you know both the pills and
the monster's glowing eyes happen to be
purple just like the torment fragments
and just like purple guy william afton
in five nights at freddy's i don't know
why purple is the universal color of
evil but apparently it is in short
monsino appears to be harnessing the
energy that exists behind carrie's door
or who knows other doors just like hers
to create addictive and deadly products
and it looks like they might not be the
only ones trying to harness that energy
let's go back to where it all started
the door in the woods as i mentioned
earlier the original design for the door
featured the happy face symbol
representing the sunny family cult
crip's second longest running series and
the other major hub connecting the wider
monster verse on the surface this is
just a story of a girl trying to live a
normal life with her not-so-normal
family of serial killers but the
narrative also heavily features
prophecies from an ancient tome of
monsters huh ancient tome of monsters
you say now where have i seen something
like that before oh yeah the girl in the
woods trailer the reappearance of the
tome in the trailer is why i suspect
that the sunny family cult symbol is
still on that door just edit it out of
the trailers or maybe it's coming later
in the series when a cult member visits
the door as i talked about in our
previous crypt tv theory about the
look-see season 3 of the sunny family
cult focuses on the character roger as
he tries to carry out a demonic ritual
from the book meant to transform him
into a new creature specifically the
tome calls out that there must be five
blood sacrifices and the fifth has to be
performed by a 17 year old girl with
dark hair and dark eyes i saw it in
visions a beautiful girl of 17.
violence
etched into her soul
you'll be the one who helps me transform
into something greater than myself
something stronger
and more
pure and by the season's end he's done
it he finds a dark featured girl who's
willing to stab him in the chest in the
final shot of sunny family cult season 3
we see his dead hand suddenly twitch as
it comes back to life transformed but
into what exactly now in my last theory
i thought that roger could have been
transformed into a second look-see
monster but after re-examining all the
evidence i'm not convinced anymore the
second look-see appears to be a female
notice the bow shape that's on her head
which doesn't really match up with roger
but more importantly this new look-see
was actually introduced before the
finale of sunny family cult went up on
the channel additionally during all
these lead-up scenes we see repeated
flashes of all the other existing
monsters in the cryptoverse the looksy
the birch mordeo even the then unknown
soot who would be revealed in the very
next main upload so why would the luxie
be in these flashes if roger was just
gonna transform into the look-see after
he already existed with other mazda and
it's confusing you know no the simpler
answer here is that the ritual wasn't to
create another one of an existing
monster it was to welcome in someone new
to give rise to a new creature and
wouldn't you know it the next main
upload onto the channel would be of
course the door in the woods the video
that introduces us to carrie and crip's
newest strongest creature the brute a
humanoid creature who walks around
shirtless like roger has symbols
tattooed on him like roger and is is
that a stab wound in the middle of his
chest just like roger a monster that
hadn't been seen or referenced in any
tomes or tattoos or texts anywhere up to
that point something entirely brand new
created from the ritual not only that
but he lives behind a door that just so
happens to have the sunny family cult
symbol on it a symbol that we know the
cult tends to leave behind on doors when
they've made a killing i think then that
this is the true nature of the brute
it's roger it is a roger that has been
transformed via this ritual and that my
friends is my prediction for where all
of this is headed and honestly it's why
i'm so excited to see what this new girl
in the woods series has in store for us
because not only are you starting with
the solid premise of a girl fighting to
redeem herself for the mistakes of her
past against literal hell spawn using a
hidden blade but based on the fact that
we're already seeing the monster tome in
the trailer buried in the season of
streaming could be references easter
eggs and connections to the widest and
coolest monster verse that's ever been
put to screen will we get to see what
the plane of torment is actually like
will the sunny family cult make a
surprise appearance in front of the door
maybe a brief glimpse of a look-see or
the birch somewhere in the woods could
we get more clues to either confirm or
deny the mysterious origins of the
deadly brute honestly i don't know but
what i do know is that i am dying to
find out but hey that's just a theory a
film theory
and cuts
[Music]
you